and then you have islamists who are
there who um will chant things in Arabic
that people around them if you don't
speak Arabic or if you don't are not
familiar with the chance you don't even
realize how extreme they are like so I
recorded some of them chanting about Kar
which um is a it's a chant referencing
uh a time a part of Islamic tradition
stories that um Muhammad's Army in the
Century in Arabia slaughtered and killed
um Jewish communities and they they have
a chant Associated to that so and they
they use they they said the Muhammad's
Army is coming is coming for the Jews
and where they use uses yahud they don't
say israelit to see Jews
so if you're just around there and
you're you don't understand this you
wouldn't even realize it um there have
been speakers um at some of these
so-called Pro Palestine rallies that are
lit Lally calling for
Jihad um and urging for um Muslim armies
these are their words to wage
shod Andy know we have not done this in
a long time it's been like what four or
five years since we've seen each other
in person we were unclear what country
it was in but here we are in London at
ARK and I'm very thankful to to be here
in makes it special there given that
there's so much time has passed there's
a lot to talk about there is a lot to
talk about unfortunately I think a lot
of the things that you've been warning
about on the ground really starting in
Portland Seattle Pacific Northwest but
antifa and BLM a lot of that now has the
chaos around that has kind of spread all
over the world um but here we are in
London first so let let's let's do that
first uh why are you here at ARC do a
little of that and then we'll get into
the nitty-gritty
well I'm here at ARC um as an intende to
I I think we're a couple years now or or
I just say number of months after what
governments did to the world because of
pandemic lockdowns and I think people
have moved on and they just forgotten
how bad things were there and um
there's how people how people should be
having discussions are in person and I I
I feel like a lot of people have
forgotten that they've gotten so used to
the zooms meetings the the YouTube
videos and all that which is a great
form of communication but getting
together in person is it's different I'm
sure you can test that us if we did this
interview by a Skype it's very different
than you and I sitting in front of one
another so having a a conference um in
person in London where all us can come
together with these different ideas many
ENT ideas counter ideas on on um how
Society could potentially be better
organize that's something I want to be a
part of and um I'm still angry that uh
our lives were disrupted for years shut
down for years um because of government
policies yeah and what you're sort of
known for is being on the ground at a
lot of these events over the years and
the protests and the riots and the
violence that we've seen in so many of
our CI ities um and now we're seeing a
sort of new version of that we've sort
of seen the BLM antifa thing to me it's
like the mask came off almost overnight
and now here in London just over the
last couple days you you've been at some
of these what I would say are Hamas
rallies I don't think that they're Pro
pales rallies they strike me as Hamas
rallies uh but I'll let you uh discuss
that if you think that's a fair
estimation and what do you make of
what's going on the ground here it in so
many European cities so uh most people
are probably familiar with my work
because of my writings and videos
related to antio but actually before
that one of my main beats was I wrote
about and talked about radical
Islam uh Muslim migration and
integration that was one of the things
that people hated me for actually
there's a long list of things that
people hate you for I'm on that list too
I got a list that they hate me for it's
all right so I I've been able to to
bring out like the knowledge and skill
set that I have from that prior type of
coverage um in covering the recent
demonstrations of the last 3 weeks uh
since the summit of uh October which is
when Hamas um launched its Terror
attacks in southern Israel um I've been
on the ground in London covering the
demonstrations some of them have been
very extreme some have been violent uh
and I've also been keeping an eye on
what's been happening in the US at the
University campuses and cities Coast to
Coast what I've observed in the US is
that
the uh the agitators and those who are
shown up shown up for the direct actions
in America are the same actors as those
who are involved in the BLM antifa
unrest in
2020 um I can you talk about that for a
second from like an operational level
how is it that it seems like as I said
almost overnight BLM just we had two
years of crazy BLM antifa riots and all
of that stuff it cooled off for two
years under Biden and then just
basically overnight they've turned it on
again that that's that's not just an
accident yes that's that's an accurate
observation I mean it was literally
overnight that I mean actually was was
the same day on the 7th of October that
people showed up in many cities for
these celebration rallies so how how
they did it is because in 2020 they had
months to strengthen develop Andor
strengthen the so-called nonprofit
profit groups um that are very uh Adept
at Grassroots organizing access to huge
email list serves and leftwing groups
all all leftwing groups um and so
they're just able to send out mass
emails get up uh the digital Flyers
which takes just minutes to make and
just get it this information out show up
here at this time
ASAP and um we've we have a whole
generation of um American Youth who were
radicalized just a few years ago and now
they're they're they're ready to be the
foot soldiers again for the latest cause
um it doesn't matter that they are
completely ignorant about the history of
conflict between um the state of Israel
or how Israel was even founded that that
history conflicted Israel and its Arab
neighbors um they're ignorant about the
history of Palestinian nationalism it
doesn't matter it's just as you've
probably observed and viewers listeners
observed that they've recycled a lot of
the same chance from BLM no justice no
peace there's um hatred of police
sentiment hatred of America sentiment
it's it's the same you could say
grievances now there's a new one tacked
on which is the the pal so-call
Palestinian grievance um the difference
between the American one the American
protests demonstrations and the the ones
that have been happening in Europe um
there's there's an important distinction
in that the ones that are happening in
London um and in in Europe have an
element of radical Islam to it that is
more predominant than in America right
so from an American perspective it seems
to mostly be like confused college
students who are just kind of Pawns not
to say there's no element of it but here
the islamist element is way stronger
correct yeah so yes so I'm glad you
brought that from the islamist uh
element so if you aren't familiar with
islamist islamism it's it's about
political organizing or political
identity around a Muslim identity and
Europe has had um because of um bad
integration policies there's been two
generations or more of Muslim British
Muslim Europeans who
um uh some of them have been radicalized
in a separatist identity uh there are
organizations that are established here
and other countries in Europe that
really push
the grievance against wider Society so
what I witness being on the ground um
covering many many huge demonstrations
here is
that there's a leftist element to it in
that you have white British people who
are part of socialist groups or
communist groups who are coming to
recruit in fact they're kind of at the
Forefront of the formal organizing
aspect of it like the they will hand out
the pla guards to people you'll see
Socialist Workers parties on these signs
um they have tables and booths set up
for people and they literally set up
right outside the tube station so these
people show up and they just hand them
stuff and then they're out there it's a
Well oiled machine and then you have
islamists who are there who um will
chant things in Arabic that people
people around them if you don't speak
Arabic or if you don't are not familiar
with the chance you don't even realize
how extreme they are like so I recorded
some of them chanting about Kar which um
is a it's a chant referencing uh a time
a part of Islamic tradition stories that
um Muhammad's Army in the sth century in
Arabia slaughtered and killed um Jewish
communities and they they have a chant
Associated to that so so and they they
use they they said that Muhammad's Army
is coming is coming for the Jews and
where the use uses yahood they don't say
Israelites to say Jews
so if you're just around there and
you're you don't understand this you
wouldn't even realize it um there have
been speakers um at some of these
so-called Pro Palestine rallies that are
literally calling for
Jihad um and urging for um Muslim armies
these are their Awards to wage Jihad in
Israel so they very much view it un not
just in Israel here right so they've
been really careful in their language
because so in Britain um there's no
First Amendment and there is anti-terror
legislation that has restrictions on
speech and because some of these uh
radical Muslim activists and groups have
been prosecuted because they will be
much more explicit some of the speakers
here have been a bit more um they've
given themselves enough of plausible Den
deniability in fact it became a little
bit of a scandal here two weeks ago
because during the speeches about Jihad
and calling for Muslim armies to engage
in Jihad and against Israel um the Met
police in London you posted this right
it was incredible yeah they were
responding on social media well we have
people on our team analyzing the speech
and Jihad has a number of meanings so
it's like this is what I mean when it's
like the the extreme speakers
are they're playing with the language in
a way that can fool who they need to
fool right which is by the way I mean
they're doing that in the states as well
because when they champ from The River
To The Sea it's obviously a call for
genocide we know what's between the
river in the sea they're not going to
get out there and say kill all the Jews
then then you have a First Amendment
problem but so they're playing with the
language do you think that that well
we're here in London so do you think the
UK is set up properly to deal with this
I mean it it seems like there is an
invasion that that's what it feels like
to me and I think to a lot of people
when they're seeing the videos that
you're posting so there's been three
pro-israel only three pro-israel
protests in in London since uh the
attacks the first one didn't happen
until a whole week after and I think
because the um the British Jewish
Community is genuinely afraid to hold a
large public gathering understandably uh
there was a lot of police protection for
all of them one of the uh rallies was
outside the police headquarters by a
organization called um campaign against
anti-Semitism and what they were
advocating for is that the the extremist
chants and speeches and uh signs that
have been shown at some of these rallies
that police need to enforce the law and
prosecute um arrest and then prosecutors
need to actually prosecute based on hate
speech legislation or incitement to
violence or incitement to racial hatred
they actually have all those laws here I
um I haven't seen at least in the
mainstream discussions
about migration and
immigration um
there's I think this is a an
uncomfortable reality for white British
to acknowledge or accept but what I've
witnessed and seen and
um at these rallies that I go to is that
there's a there's a sense of religious
and racial Consciousness with with some
of these um British Muslim communities
that is on a whole another level
that um the average person doesn't
really understand like these people are
not they're not just there to show up
with the sign and chant they
really I have a dedication a solidarity
with their brothers and sisters as the
words they would use in Palestine that
um is much more extreme than showing up
for a protest and leaving and I think
this points to
um questions
about immigration policies in Britain in
the past um but but what do they do
forward I mean I think a lot of people
at least on the DL are saying okay we
really screwed up this immigration thing
it's obviously partly at least why
brexit happen but yet here we are I mean
is there anyone politically that has the
power or the will to to fix some of this
whatever whatever that means I mean this
seems to be the question that everyone
is asking privately but nobody's talking
about publicly um within the mainstream
part to S uh by the way you were at an
event last night a battle of ideas or
event where you basically asked this and
didn't get an answer so I'm posing the
same question to you
now well within Labor uh which is the
the central party and the conservative
party the central right uh party in the
ukuk neither one are neither one have
offered an analysis through discussion
about immigration in fact just a few
weeks ago the the Home Secretary which
is um she's the head of the the UK
equivalent of the of um uh DHS she has
spoken about uh the failures of
multiculturalism Inver and anytime
anybody in public speaks about it they
are just they're destroyed by the Ching
classes in media and it's
like
just I I would encourage people to go to
some of these um so-called Pro Palestine
rallies and see go and see you can you
think this is a a success story about
British integration but it's not just a
story about Britain same story in France
I mean in fact in France there the
government there is so afraid of um
anti-Semitic incitement incitement to
anti-semitic violence that they've
actually banned um the uh Pro Palestine
rallies people have shown up but they're
not doing anything about it I mean they
they sent police out but I mean it's you
have th tens of thousands of people in
central Baris and some of these
demonstrations and I mean police will
fire off tear gas and all that I it's
just an an observation I had is like
Poland and and Hungary have been
uh they face a lot of um uh propaganda
against them in liberal media Western
media and through the EU uh so through
institutions as well and particularly
about how they've in the last decade
have been um they've been they refused
to be strong armed by the EU into
accepting large numbers of Muslim
migrants and U they've also historically
have resisted that as well um and it's
it's not in these places that you see
attacks on synagogues of Jewish people
being killed or targeted it's in places
that
are like in France um in ban um in
Germany in Sweden what would your
warning then be for someone that has
been you've been warning about this
stuff in America now you're warning
about this stuff here in Britain what
would your warning be for Americans or
or is there any anything we should be
doing politically to to deal with some
of this before it fully hits us even
though it feels like it it might be
hitting us
already we saw Americans we saw what the
BLM grievance rage was able to do to
America in 2020 because of the allies
and coalitions that BLM was able to
build up with antifa and all these other
radical groups groups now they've been
able to pull in another grievance group
this being Muslim Americans or Arab
Americans uh that's really dangerous and
um they're so clear in their inment to
VI violence you can see it in what some
what's been revealed about many of these
academics I mean these aren't these
aren't just radicals who are showing up
um on the streets that nobody cares
about these are people who
access to young people in academic
institutions and are radicalized Z and
in my view it's this is a thread of this
the same ideology of blood lust of a
hatred against the country America and
wanting hating it so much that they
endorse terrorism against America and
its allies and Friends
internationally um we have a homegrown
radicalization issue isue in America
it's on the left this is It's a failure
of all the um counter extremism or hate
watch groups in America like splc ADL
and all that we have this whole industry
that's been very very good within Civil
Society to research encounter and expose
faric extremism Bravo to them for that I
don't fault them for doing that type of
work I think that type of
exposure um in in knowledge needs to be
out there but where is it on the far LA
not only do they not do it they're part
of it yeah right that's the Twisted part
that's the Twisted part well uh Andy I
suspect well first off we're going to do
this more than once every three years
that's number one but I do want to say
on a personal note you know when you
started doing this thing you were you a
student at Portland State when we first
met years ago I was we was one of the
first events that I ever did a free
speech event where I was being protested
and called a Nazi and you were a student
at Portland State covering it and youve
become really like one of the well
you're on the very short list of
journalists that I don't have to go like
this when I say journalist and put air
quotes So on a personal note I'm very
proud of your success and and you're
brave you're genuinely Brave a lot of
people in this kind of fake it but
you're still out there and it's come at
Great cl to you I'm sure well not only
physically but emotionally and
everything else so I'm glad you're still
on the fight my friend thank you very
much St then I I just want to say like
how thankful that I am for the the work
you've done all these years there's been
a a lot of YouTubers who have dropped
off the scene you've been through I
means it's many years now and it's
really nice to see this consistent
figure and face and voice and and thank
you for giving a platform to so many of
us who we were starting out our careers
and were unknown figures I got nothing
better to do than save the world so
let's do it huh if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a ver of topics watch our
full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell